yes yeah because that that's like
nothing
yeah she's going yeah if any if anything
that that increases her value to a high
value man if she if she's letting him
exercise his options
like i think
remember we have to think about it
there's not a lot of rich guys out here
you know not actually isn't you know
there's a lot of guys that that you
might think they're not i know that
actually there isn't a lot of rich that
i have had so i've heard the steps and
it doesn't add up yeah so when it's like
when when a girl meets a guy that's rich
don't understand like
you're probably not going to meet
another guy like that in the next
hundred guys that you see
don't understand i think i keep on
thinking like a guy stop saying yeah so
it's like you have to take your chances
when it comes and if a rich guy
looked like he was talking about the
drake video
i guarantee obviously that was a video
and it's entertainment but i guarantee
if he wanted to do that 100 100
and girls will they'll be
perfectly fine with it